[Music]
in snapchat detective Muse submitted by
s Ock is oh my gosh is that because of
the kiss of thing I don't know we're not
gonna get in touch till you guys after a
male student use snapchats gender filter
to pose as an underage girl and busting
a pedophile cough stupid is this [ __ ]
cop that you should tell filter really
you should see well look at the filters
I had that we did yeah it looks really
good like filters not neat oh yeah add
it to the me they did I get to the
measure
cuz when it when the face moves and the
eyes avoids but it's a picture Nikki is
one that made it look identical to her
brother really yeah but then she also
already kind of looks like a rotor so
you done they do look a lot of like so
this is so this happened in California
and San Mateo and this college student
he used the filter to look like a girl
this is what he looks like he does look
very young look like a girl that's a
woman for sure
it does look like an underage girl -
yeah she looks really young and I guess
if you don't use snapchat you're like oh
you don't you don't know you know you
don't know that's a theme
alright forgot those cops don't even use
that chat even look like a filter to you
I don't he's the cop that that baited a
pedophile no the cops a pedophile the
cops a pedophile that baited the cops
can be pedophiles work they can that's
what I said that's what I said thank you
so tell her I was correcting her I said
cops is the company yeah yeah I already
admitted that you're saying that can't
be pedophile I didn't say that hey bar
you're right you're right Barton you're
right
why supporting Nazis for
all right so my party of us start here
thank you
yeah so the college students name is
Ethan and so he posted this photo and
created a tinder account posing as a 19
year old girl named Esther and so that's
when this cop hit up Esther and by the
way the cops name is Rob Robert is it 19
on the safe side yeah but the thing is
they move the conversation from tinder
to snapchat and that's where like when
they were talking in snapchat is when
Esther told Rob that she was actually 16
and then so he was like oh you're gonna
probably you're only 16 and then see if
there's grass on the field play ball
under a tree listen I know what it is
but like I had a visit visualization of
pubes with better crap underage pubes
know like peu près under H pubes are
just as strong and legit as there's
probably even stronger probably
disgusting no stinky yeah no underage
pubes like puppy hair or you guys say
Steve
I don't know Gia's a Nazi I guess or
something that guy's mine I've never
heard that before where did you even
hear yeah so I actually said that theme
was a conversation to snapchat it was
actually kick and then after they had
yeah this other cheek cheek I can
finally get somebody from you're younger
than me I got you I don't know who's
right that's how I read it so you got me
cuz I'm even with a [ __ ] it's another
message
I feel so young right now he yeah it's
keek keek sounds like some underage [ __ ]
though yeah yeah okay okay but I always
pronounce it kick I don't know I don't
use the it's cuz we ate
I hope I'm right I thought it was kite
it could be that's what you took Geo
anymore oh my god
anyway all right so then that's when
they move to snapchat and then that's
when it got more explicit I got a
question um so when he went the student
was on tinder
what was his objective to just [ __ ] with
someone perfect question thank you for
asking
so it was because he had found out that
a really close friend of his who's a
girl was sexually like assaulted somehow
or molested and so she so he got really
upset about that and he took it upon
himself to pose as a girl and try to
catch online predators oh I mean this
dude robbed just so happens to be a cop
yeah that's some Jamali detective [ __ ]
right it is you know be the catfish
himself crazy too is like the cop is
pretty like cute free enjoy noob he is
handsome oh he's got caveman qualities
pedophiles
he has what caveman qualities really he
looks a little cro-magnon
he looks like you'd be like extra and
like Hurt Locker or something is it this
jaws bigger than his brain area I may be
on the spectrum of pedophile though he's
like borderline like gating there
why Porter's getting here all this
pedophile yeah it is
but then it's not as bad as a
three-year-old like when I think
pedophile I think toddlers three that's
what y'all say I think it's time no
because when you think of pedophile you
don't think like okay like people still
fantasize about high school girls you're
saying there's a spectrum and he's like
like barely know he's in there but he's
the beginner he's a more integrity level
he's still bad but he's like the JV of
pedophiles yeah
he's like in certain countries it
wouldn't be considered exactly could
some countries exchange girl your brain
girl I gotta find a way to defend this
this guy I'm just I'm just making a
statement that in the spectrum of
pedophiles there's no murders his wife
at least he suffocated with a pillow
he didn't stab her 87 times ago J right
even in court they would charge him a
yeah like there's a premeditated murder
there's like like pipe like first degree
second degree what is he this is a this
is this is like a first degree pedophile
all right so that's one Ethan so he put
his phone on airplane mode when they
were talking on snapchat and when things
were getting more explicit so he did
that so he can take screenshots and then
not let Rob know that he was taking
screenshots more yeah so then he finally
do that he compiled all this information
he sent it to Silicon Valley Crime
Stoppers tip line
and that's when he also informed them
that he was a police officer which he
had figured out from Clues that he had
dropped from their conversations
together and that's when the San Jose
police arrested him following a three
week investigation and so now he's being
held at the Santa Clara County Jail on a
50-thousand dollar bond that's amazing
so I mean my question is even if you
didn't do anything as long as you were
thinking about it as a pedophile you
already go to jail cuz I mean that's not
a real girl I'm sure or like a 60 maybe
they were setting up to meet up and
maybe that at that point she was already
gonna do it we don't know how explicit
the conversations gonna do that under
our oh but it's not as bad as they make
it seem maybe got it like a lot worse we
also can't read what was if he said the
dick pic that's pedophile you go to jail
really have what is this from a
newspaper in the library
I know right the [ __ ] thing movies
I'm like oh what the [ __ ] newspaper
it flips through a grayscale thing yeah
like I want to find some ancient
information monocalcium a at the library
that they have that [ __ ] there oh think
you've use it I've seen it oh I guess
usually make computer I don't know does
it only have articles about where grisly
murders happened but yeah so luckily
this fool got caught and then so even
the saying that he doesn't plan on using
that photo anymore obviously because
that doesn't change it now but no he
says like he pretty much he's good he's
done he caught someone he just got his
career started that's like Batman arrest
one guy I know he's like I did it I
avenged my parents I got a quitter he's
good at it he's a quitter yeah he's a
quitter
yeah and he's passionate you just quit
oh he should be a detective he was good
yeah you should work in a pedo
Department so how long is the guy gonna
be in jail for I don't know they still
like this he's on paid leave yeah yeah I
don't know any cops that just get like
fired they could do like the worst
[ __ ] job
they're like yeah he murdered 30 people
but paid leave it's like cop shoots a
homeless guy 87 times and they like paid
leave take a couple weeks maybe our
promotion you don't know yet yeah that's
pretty crazy I don't know some cities
are crazy they did talk about engaging
in sexual activity oh that girl art
through text I wonder if that was rare
for him to be like oh yeah I'm playing
with my you know what I mean like for
the guy to be like sending the text
messages about what he was doing with
himself like my dick is so it I mean my
vagina's so yeah true true I did with a
jam come on and then he's all like first
I'm gonna check off these are questions
only you would ask
[Laughter]
wait I'm kind of horny okay going to
jail like the South Park episode where
he dresses up like a prostitute one of
my favorite he [ __ ] guy yeah and then
arrests them at the end of the thought
he starts liking it so he goes
undercover he's like I gotta say like I
think it was Randy yeah he's like I
gotta go undercover and catch these
[ __ ] John's and stuff yeah and then
catching people soliciting prostitutes
yeah by [ __ ] them and interesting cuz
he needs evidence
like the semen in his bike suckin their
dicks yeah he's like you're under arrest
with a mouthful of [ __ ] yeah and he
starts to like it too much so he always
use it as an excuse to get it I think
yeah I don't know I did when I was
little like too little and I didn't like
it
alright maybe it's like you're too young
to get it going not yeah yeah how long
has it been going it got better with
time yeah yeah yeah I don't know like
all over ten it has to be for sure
easily yeah I think yeah it's like 14
seasons ISM do they still have the same
writers yeah still the same team yeah
cycle people through I actually do a guy
who wrote for the show um but the main
heads yeah but yeah get credit for it
you just go in the writers room
it's like Bill Hader like he goes there
sometimes he's in us all guy and he goes
there sometimes and just helps them
pitch [ __ ] out and then you don't really
get credit you just kind of go you know
what I realized why I don't like it it's
actually tied to a memory of my
childhood - yeah
so like I remember going like about the
pollen arrow yeah I'm about to pull an
arrow it actually feels good okay so um
talk about Bert I remember I was at some
like a family friend's house and then
they were having like a barbecue or
something and then there was like some
of my family members there and then like
strangers I didn't know and South Park
was playing on the TV for the kids to
watch because the adults were getting
drunk [ __ ] fine and then committee
it was just like a cartoon so then I
remember like I wanted to go to the
kitchen and get something and when I
walk into the kitchen I see one of the
men in the group he pulled down his
pants he was moaning everyone like
drunken behavior
I remember seeing like the hairiest has
ever oh my god oh my god so [ __ ]
truth like oh my god this person cuz I
came you the person like the person was
wearing my family bells like oh my god
where they gay like are they trying to
like I don't know my mind was it was
just one guy and he thought he was gay
lers the two dudes pulling their pants
down it was one guy pulling his pants
moaning another guy's face that was
really little so I just remembered I'm
pulling that arrow out of my heart that
that [ __ ] is connected to that or like
South Park is connected to that memory
damn you're so good good job dude a guy
mooning another guy like by pulling his
face near his ass is like the cultural
dance with my people
yeah it is we know the drunk white
people yeah and it transcended into Boy
Scouts soon as I've witnessed do so many
times yeah I saw a lot of white asses
growing up
[Music]